le fait de présenter un faux pas c'est
désormais passible d'une amende de 2000
euros contre 135 euros auparavant les
établissements recevant du public ont
également la possibilité de vérifier
l'identité de leurs clients alors bonne
ou mauvaise idée on en parle ce soir
avec notre invité pascal blasik bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes donc restaurateur à
touré membre de l'umih l'union des
métiers des industries de l'hôtellerie
votre organisation patronale l'umih
s'est prononcé contre l'application du
contrôle d'identité dans les restaurants
pour éviter notamment des conflits à
l'entrée est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec cette prise de position alors un
oui tout à fait le la problématique
c'est que nous ne sommes pas assez
remonté ça c'est un point qui écrit qui
est assez qui assez critiquable et qui
est critiquée sur le principe et 2 c'est
le temps que cela induit il faut savoir
que derrière on est ce que ça prend du
temps de contrôler le passé en plus il
doit contrôler l'identité
c'est ça va être un temps qu'il va être
infinie de refuser de le faire
aujourd'hui c'est c'est quoi la position
la position du syndicat s'est on ne
contrôle pas les identités on contrôle
les passes on reste aux passes mais les
identités ça ne nous c'est pas notre
travail vous avez un prénom féminin sur
le passé un homme en face de vous qu'est
ce que vous faites pour comprenez bien
que ça correspond à leur demandera est
ce que c'est bien votre passé la
personne qu'on prendra tout de suite si
elle n'est pas d'as ici un quiproquo
qu'on l'a repéré le problème c'est
savoir c'est pas vraiment contrôler
identité on peut très bien aussi avoir
des faux vrais pasri est le vrai
problème est là quand vous avez des gens
qui arrivent avec un pass il ya leur nom
leur prénom mais en fin de compte ils
n'ont pas été vaccinés ils ont
simplement payer leurs passes comment
voulez vous que nous nous puissions dire
s'il a cette personne-là peut rentrer il
peut pas rentrer est-ce que déjà dans
votre quotidien vous avez eu affaire à
des gens qui présentait défaut parce que
vous avez remarqué sur sur dans mon
établissement je parle pour moi j'en ai
pas eu je sais qu'il ya quelques
établissements qui on est
ce déboire mais c'était tellement
flagrant que ça se passait assez
rapidement c'est comme ont
présenté une fausse carte étudiant une
fausse carte d'identité quand vous avez
la tête correspond pas vraiment à ce
qu'ils on vous dit un ses impasses de
filles et c'est un garçon ou linverse ça
soit facilement donc les gens ont reculé
s'en vont sans problème la problématique
c'est que ça risque de créer des
tensions et des
idées des agglomérats à l'entrée des
établissements alors pour une un système
qu'il faut éviter que les gens soient
regroupées c'est pas vraiment la bonne
méthode alors le 2 février doit marquer
la fin de l'obligation de du télétravail
les salariés vont pouvoir sortir de chez
eux et aller déjeuner à nouveau le medic
peut être dans vos établissements est ce
que cette mesure clairement a nui à
votre commerce le télétravail alors là
la mise en place du système buts et de
travail forcé comme a été mis dans le
système de l'état sa nuit oui au
principe que le midi pour le système de
centre-ville on est moins 30 moins 50 %
de taux d'occupation le problème 1 c'est
que ça fait une baisse de chiffre
d'affaires conséquente le problème 2
c'est que cela induit et va induire un
mode de consommation si différents vous
pensez que les gens vont prendre
l'habitude finalement de rentrer chez
eux ou de plus à l'est dans les
brasseries pour manger le midi ceci peut
être potentiellement le cas et ça a été
le cas quand sa ré ouvert où il ya une
une perte de
de flux par rapport à avant qu vidal à
l'ouverture kevin le mili que
pensez-vous de l'augmentation des
salaires acté dans le secteur de
l'hôtellerie de la restauration
justement on parlait de d'un minimum une
rémunération minimum de 5% au-dessus du
smic et une augmentation moyenne de 16%
sur toute la grille des salaires est-ce
que c'est facilement
finançables j'allais lire dans vos
établissements où vous recevez moins de
monde justement alors la grille a été
mis en place en fin de compte pour acter
des choses qui existait déjà donc ça ne
va pas trop évolué sionnel
le travail il faut savoir quand même que
les 5% d'augmentation de base c'est
pratiquement le double de ce qui se fait
ce que c'est ce qui s'est fait dans les
autres métiers on a une augmentation sur
2 5 2 6% sur les autres grilles oui nous
on a une augmentation de 6 5% à l'instar
à rattraper c'est par un temps on a
refait quelque chose qui existait avant
voilà on l'avait ensuite avant on avait
pour ce qu'on appelait le smic hôtelier
qui avait un taux différent on l'a on
leur mit un petit peu au goût du jour de
plus nous l'umih ça fait quand même des
années qu'on travaille sur le bien-être
des entreprises aidées des
collaborateurs on a mis un plat 1 place
le paiement des de la mutuelle payée par
l'entreprise
les repas sont payés par l'entreprise
l'umih les adhérents l'umih adhère un
cee ce qu'il donne droit à pouvoir avoir
un sérieux pour les petites entreprises
sans qui ce alors plus cher ou un petit
peu plus cher c'est 10 euros par salarié
qui va ramener des salariés vers votre
secteur alors ça c'est un peu plus
compliqué c
et c'est surtout nous ça fait des années
qu'on très concret un climat de
confiance et de bien-être entre les
salariés les patrons après pour ramener
les salariés dans notre secteur il n'y a
pas que notre secteur qui sommes en
perte de
de main d'oeuvre c'est tout laisse tous
les produits de tous les secteurs de
production vous prenez nous en national
on est à 230 mille personnes dans le btp
c'est un million quatre cent mille
ce qu'il faut c'est redonner goût aux
gens à venir travailler et savoir que
dans ses métiers et ses des métiers où
on peut s'épanouir on peut bien
travailler dans de bonnes conditions et
réussir et avancer merci merci pascal
blasik pour vous expliquer ce je vous en
prie